[Aplausos]
eu estou aqui hoje para fazer uma
pergunta pra vocês se vocês pudessem
vocês demitiriam seu chefe eu sou
estudiosos do comportamento humano ea 27
anos eu acompanho pessoas em seu
desenvolvimento de carreira eu fui me
desenvolvendo até chegar a analista
sênior na minha empresa e claro é
incentivado pelos meus pais que falavam
sempre que eu tinha que chegar lá eu
trabalhei com muita dedicação e alegria
e positividade
um belo dia é eu sempre quis ocupar
novos carros nessa empresa e um belo dia
me chamaram e falar ó água
você agora vai ser uma supervisora eu
fiquei numa felicidade só
era muita alegria tudo aquilo que os
meus pais queriam pra mim eu tinha
conseguido continuar trabalhando com
muita dedicação e positividade
porém nem tudo é perfeito meu gestor me
chamou um dia e falou assim carla
infelizmente o cenário da empresa mudou
nós não teremos mais o cargo de
supervisor da empresa
contamos com você novamente no cargo de
analista
vocês podem imaginar como eu fiquei eu
fiquei arrasada
eu no final do dia foi para casa e eu
tinha uma decisão a tomar
afinal de contas meu chefe não
valorizavam aquele ambiente de trabalho
não é o ideal para mim eu tinha
eventualmente até que pedir demissão e
eu fui pra casa no dia seguinte
naquele momento em que nós ficamos
sozinhos nós com o mesmo na frente do
espelho também uma decisão
eu não queria mais aquele
sentimento pra mim um sentimento de que
a minha carreira ea minha vida
profissional estava na mão de outras
pessoas
estava mal da empresa nesse período eu
fui me novamente absorvi essa nova
posição cheguei no trabalho e falei vou
seguir em frente e assumir essa posição
procurei fazer o meu trabalho com muita
determinação prazo qualidade antes de
entregar qualquer coisa eu pedi para um
colega checar para ver se eu tinha
esquecido alguma coisa tinha passado
alguma coisa que eu não tinha visto
quando eu podia eu colocava um pouco
mais de ousadia e qualidade inovação da
que tudo ficasse muito bom
não foi fácil durante esse período eu
continuei recebendo muitos feedbacks e
estes feedbacks me ajudaram no meu
crescimento pessoal e adquirir novos
cargos na empresa
hoje eu tenho uma equipe de quase 100
pessoas em dois países e durante essa
trajetória eu aprendi cinco lições que
eu selecionei para compartilhar com
vocês
a primeira delas é me refazer
eu acredito fortemente que eu posso
mudar o futuro o passado eu não consigo
mais fazer nenhuma alteração
eu peguei toda a minha energia e foquei
no que eu queria
a segunda lição foi resultado nada do
que eu contei para vocês até agora teria
sido verdade se eu não tivesse de fato
empregados resultados
qualquer empresa que eu for qualquer
trabalho que eu escolha é preciso
apresentar esses resultados
a terceira lição foi identificar o que
eu tenho de especial saber de fato e que
eu sou boa
eu normalmente faço uma auto avaliação
profunda de quais são
fortalezas e como essas fortalezas podem
me ajudar e ajudar as pessoas que estão
à minha volta
a quarta edição foi coragem com certeza
confesso para vocês muitos desafios que
eu aceitei nesse período eu nem sabia
direito como eu ia começar
mas eu fui lá peguei e de ajuda e
conseguir alcançar os resultados que
eram necessários para aquele desafio
a quinta edição foi é não me acomodar
eu essa semana assistir um vídeo de uma
jovem e falava que é se engana quem
acredita que o diploma vai te salvar
eu concordo com ela é muito importante
as vivências na nossa vida as vivências
nos trazem experiência e oportunidade de
aprendizado diferenciado
eu hoje faço voluntariado dou aulas faço
consultoria de carreira estou aqui com
muito frio na barriga falando com vocês
mas eu estou me movimentando eu é
aprende entende que eu não precisava do
meu chefe pra poder ser feliz no meu
trabalho eu precisava de mim eu dependia
era de mim e com certeza nessa
trajetória muitas lições eu aprendi e
com certeza vocês estão me ouvindo e
contém tirando outras lições dessa fala
eu acredito que nós precisamos ser feliz
hoje
pode ser que no final do dia vocês não
lembram mais de mim mas é muito
importante entender que a sua carreira
está nas suas mãos
seja feliz hoje e aí vocês estão prontos
para demitir seu chefe
[Aplausos]